Hey it's me, Destin. Welcome
to Smarter Every Day.
Today we-
(Jörg) Nope. [Chuckles]
Welcome to the Slingshot Channel.
[Laughs]
(Destin) As you can see, today
I've been taken over by Germans.
We're going to look at slingshots today.
The physics of slingshots.
So why do they call your channel the
Slingshot Channel? I don't understand.
(Jörg) You know, I don't understand either.
You know, you would think that
we'd call it the Nice Guys Channel
or something like that, so... No,
they called it the Slingshot Channel.
- I think it makes sense.
[Both laugh]
We're going to talk about
the energy use in bands.
Do you want to say anything about it?
- Yes. Well, this is of course the
lightest slingshot that I've ever built.
[Both laugh]
Not exactly. It's actually
the most powerful one.
The energy of a rifle shot, and it
has the momentum of a sledgehammer.
- Alright, so we'll do the
math and see if Jörg is right.
So let's look at the physics of slingshots.
Kinetic energy is 1/2 mass
times velocity squared.
For a .22 it's about 153 joules,
but for a Springfield
.30-06 it's 3841 joules.
I calculated the momentum of a sledgehammer
by smashing bricks in the back yard
and analyzing the high-speed.
It worked out to about 46 newton seconds.
There is an angle between the
band and the point of anchoring.
This angle... I'm not going to get my hand
in there, 'cause I don't want to die.
But this angle... if you take
the cosine of that angle,
that is the amount of force going
into accelerating the projectile.
So the closer the bands, the
more efficient the slingshot.
Is that correct, Jörg?
- Yes, exactly.
- Yeah, this is as awesome as it looks.
[Click, wooden clang]
(Jörg) So because it's rather cold now,
and also we kept the bands in drawn
out condition for quite a while,
the shot went low a little bit
because the rubber was a
little bit tired already,
and in cold weather rubber doesn't
work as well as in hot temperatures.
- Ah. Makes sense.
It was almost a complete momentum
transfer between that ball and the wood.
The mass-times-velocity of the
ball went all into the wood,
So the mass-times-velocity of the wood
after the shot would be equal to the ball.
[Music]
[Man speaks German]
[Click, splat]
(Destin) Yes!
[Laughs]
[Music]
So I'm Destin, and you are
getting smarter every day.
And if you want to, go check out Jörg's
channel - the Slingshot Channel.
Yeah?
- Yes. Make sure.
So I'll put a link for you to click,
so go to his channel and
if you like it, subscribe.
That's it. Bye.
(Jörg) This is the only
slingshot that I've ever built
that makes grown men giggle
like they're small girls.
[Both laugh]
- Okay, slingshots are all about turning
potential energy into kinetic energy.
So the first thing we have to do, is we
have to build up the potential energy,
so Jörg is doing that now...
with his sissy device.
[Destin giggles]
That translates, right?
[Giggles]
(Jörg) Pretty much. And I
will soon be done here, so...
- So I'll have to start running.
So this is a very, very large steel
ball, clasped here between the dowels,
and we're going to try
to destroy this pumpkin.
The pumpkin really has no chance.
It's just a question of if we can hit it.
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help